ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show a lot of fun
we're going to have this episode uh a
lot of fun but first let's do some
housekeeping i'm going to be the
ridgefield playhouse on february
25th i believe yeah
in ridgefield connecticut if you want to
grab your tickets to that small room
intimate show about 500 seats we're
gonna see
um half of them sold out today when we
announced and then hopefully we'll get
to a second show
uh
up there as well our friend janice
pappas may stop by and do some guest
spots he lives right
in that area so that should be a lot of
fun prince andrew friend of the show uh
settled a sexual uh what was it
misconduct lawsuit and civil sex case
civil sex case now you know prince
andrew friend of uh jeffrey epstein uh
jeffrey epstein and jaslane maxwell
named in uh this lawsuit uh with
virginia guffrey guffrey who claimed she
was forced to have sex with him
forced
uh to have sex with him on three
occasions in 2001 after being trafficked
by his pedophile pal jeffrey epstein and
jesus maxwell
and it was the result of intense
negotiations between both sides that
were finalized on monday a source with
knowledge
of the complex deal suggested it was
only after andrew was able to provide
proof that the remaining funds would be
available from the 17 million sale of a
swiss chalet
he owned
with his former wife
sarah ferguson
uh you know what i say to virginia uh
guffrade
get that money baby a lot of people
might be angry at her because they want
to see this guy you know you they want
to see him in jail
but these people she doesn't owe you
anything she's a trafficking victim
and listen she went through hell
and however she decides to deal with it
is how she and the queen is giving her
money
queen elizabeth to the sex abuse
charities so it's like it's interesting
to a sex abuse charity
what's the queen's name is it elizabeth
elizabeth yeah queen elizabeth donating
money to the i mean you know that's
coming up at christmas
when she talks to prince andrew
and are donated two million dollars to a
charity because of your behaviour
so you know that's going down um
a royal source said quote
she could not be seen making a payment
to a victim of sexual assault who
accused your son of being an abuser but
a deal was structured in such a way to
arrange a sizable financial contribution
to the settlement by way of a charitable
donation instead so everything's over
now covet's over epstein's over you got
to get a new script
everything is over whatever you want to
talk about is done there was no
reckoning there was no bomb that went
off there was no explosion q anon was uh
fake
nothing happened nobody went to jail
they didn't open up gitmo nobody got
locked up
nothing happened all your q and on
influencers have moved on to the vaccine
they're gonna move on from that in a few
months too
trust me uh
it's
you know
there is no season finale
that anybody was happy with and this
will be the final story
of this case which again
was a pretty
earth-shattering case that there was an
island
in this which now everyone's bored of it
already and everyone's like whatever but
let's just because we're not going to
talk about i get flack people go we want
more they go there's nothing left
we've picked it all off the bone there's
nothing here but
just a fun recap as we leave
uh the topic for a while unless there's
something new there was an island
in the south pacific
owned by a guy
who is a billionaire pedophile and
people would go to it to [ __ ] kids on
the island and those people uh were
running the world
that's all proven
that's all real and proven
and this will be the final story that
this weird kind of guy prince andrew who
seems a little he's on the spectrum
uh neurodivergent
um
is uh you know paying this woman some
money who went through hell and was
trafficked by jeffrey and gislane she's
laying i guess we'll just be in jail
until they kill her or whatever
however they're gonna deal with her but
it's over and i mean there again
there is there was no real
uh resolution
as there wasn't going to be i mean just
lane max well they'll sacrifice her
she'll end up in jail and they'll either
get rid of her or whatever is going to
happen is going to happen but
again this wasn't going to bring down
like all the dominoes were not going to
fall here i mean that's
pretty obvious to everyone now this is
seemingly the final story this reminds
me of cove and now it's like
it's like they're taking the last mask
you know they're gonna take the mask off
the last kid at gym and they'll be like
and done
and they throw it in the garbage run
free run free and breathe now
sorry we masked you for two years
outside
seems insane
run free and bring so this is what it is
now i mean
blackmail is gone i guess pretty digital
i'm sure that you'll still see a
honeypot here and there but this is the
uh
this is it
and they'll they'll sell that island
they'll flip that island to somebody
else
who'll do the same thing on it probably
what is that island suited for what are
you gonna do
blackrock which is uh the
what's amazing to me now is the uh
the
and we've been following this i spoke to
mullen about it when i was in new york
and he made some great points about
corporate landlords just owning
everything in america individual
landlords
uh disappearing people not having to pay
their rent so then a lot of these
landlords have to sell their properties
and then um
you know who comes in and buys them
blackrock blackrock or blackstone same
thing right
um
blackstone buys 12
uh sun belt apartments for 5.8 billion
dollars
um
this is from zero hedge wall street
won't rest until it becomes the biggest
and perhaps only landlord in the u.s
on wednesday blackstone cemented its
position as america's largest
residential and commercial landlord by
buying uh apartment owner preferred
apartment communities in a deal valued
at 5.8 billion demonstrating the
unstoppable investor demand for
multi-family
i.e rental properties in sun belt
states
according to wall street journal
blackstone will pay 25 a share in cash
for the atlanta-based real estate
investment trust
that that represents a premium of
roughly 39 over the closing price on
february the 9th the day
before bloomberg news reported the reit
was exploring options including a sale
so the deal includes more than 40 uh
rental apartment properties including 12
000 units in states uh including florida
tennessee and georgia that's what they
mean by sun belt preferred apartment
also owns 54 grocery anchored shopping
centers anchored by grocery stores
probably like publix
about 70 of the deal's value is in its
rental apartments wow
so black stone
now they're ramping up its bet on u.s
rental housing blackstone i want you to
think about this is fun we like we like
we like to read the article and go huh
why is this this keeps falling down here
i keep
i keep adjusting this and it doesn't
matter it just keeps um
so listen to this blackstone has been
aggressively
ramping
up its bet on u.s
rental housing the firm has agreed to
buy two other companies that own
apartments in the past two months
building up his presence in states
including colorado texas arizona and
georgia well what do they mean by that
ramping up its bet
on u.s rental
housing well they're betting
and they're correct
that people are not going to be able to
own
homes
or that more people
in the future
are going to rent
this is their bet
and they're probably correct because the
cost of home ownership in this country
is
i mean
ludicrous
especially in places where you'd want to
live
so companies like blackstone go
listen the future
is going to be
the gig economy
where you have people that hop from gig
to gig
and they're going to be permanent
renters
and that's what it's going to be
they're not going to own property they
may not even own a car
they're going to use services like uber
and lyft and
they're going to rent an apartment
they're not going to own much of
anything
and according to that article you're
going to love it you're going to be
happy and you know the american dream is
is is uh turning from
home ownership and family to something
else entirely
it's really what it's becoming it used
to be the american dream as as stated
now
you know the
how possible it was and
you know whether it was legit then
certainly more legit seeming than now
yes of course it didn't include every
but what about non-binary poets i know
yes i know that that's
yes thank you
they were left out
but the american dream it was a family
and property kind of right community
based on those things family property
you own property you have a family
you're in a community there's industry
the community thrives everybody kind of
succeeds together fails together there's
an investment there are social
commitments things are more local now
things are global
you don't have a family everybody lives
in a city everybody's alone
everybody's unonly fans flicking their
bean
everybody's taking multiple pills just
to get out of bed in the morning and
then another round of pills just to get
back into bed at night
people are severed from their community
they're severed
from any social commitments
the only communities they're a part of
are digital communities
that are incredibly toxic
that are centered around overthrowing
the government or owning a picture of an
ape
but
life has changed the american dream has
changed and blackstone gets this they
know where we're going they're not
dummies
they can see it they go how the hell
they can afford this
they're going to rent and they'll be
happy to do it
people go why do i need a home i don't
have a family
you know i don't why do i need a home
you know i have houses and i don't
really need houses but they're good
investments and
i like houses and i certainly have
friends over but i don't i don't need a
house because i don't have a family so i
don't
need a house but i guess nobody needs
anything but the reason to have it like
ben and his wife always remind me that i
don't need
a home they always go you don't need to
live in a house you don't have a family
because they're heterosexuals so they're
gonna have a family so it means they
deserve a house so i should give my
house to them
i have multiple homes i should give them
all to them but that's the point
because i don't need it as a gay guy
who's single i don't need square footage
i don't need space
i'm to give it to them
uh well no
they can get it they can get their own
but i'm always constantly told i don't
need a house and they're they're they're
they're right to that to an extent
because i don't have a family
but that is why most people buy houses
so as families
um
you know family formation is low and
it's happening later in life people just
don't need to buy [ __ ] houses now
you've brought up an interesting chart
here the national rent index up 18
year over year why don't you tell the
people
about this chart that you've
brought up so it's why are you laughing
i didn't i didn't ever say you didn't
eat at home you and your wife have
constantly
i've never said that you've constantly
if a house has like seven bedrooms
before i'm like i don't think you need
seven bedrooms i think i've said that
but i don't think i've said it but it's
it's because
yes it is
you've made me feel bad
for being gay
and you've said that gay people don't
deserve homes well gay people a lot of
us have more money than you as a
straight person because if you didn't
meet me you'd be working
tilling the land
i don't know what the hell you'd be
doing but gay people have higher than
average incomes and they're creative but
you're telling what if i want to adopt
kids what if i want to adopt uh
uh children
i'm i'm for that to fill the rooms buy
the space and and fill fill the rooms
now if i adopted a child
would i could you get it for me and
figure it out
yeah it's a long process though you need
little well how involved do i have to be
i read a book about it it's a problem
why didn't you read a book about it it
was in uh you read a book about gay
adoption no not gay adoption but just
adoption in general it was
in bubble watson's book he's a pga tour
player he talks about adopting kids and
it took him a long time yeah it took
even bubble watson he's got tons of
money he's a millionaire he had to get
on planes
though no no he's sober he's dead sober
oh who's the drunk who loves trump uh
john daly yeah because him i get they go
let's give it a take a beat before we
give you a kid
but so it's i've always heard this that
adoption is very hard that's my whole
thing with abortion
abort and i'm for abort but i'm like
listen maybe we make adoption easier so
that it's not we're not putting these
kids in uh mills
right
it's a nice timeout for the woman nine
months nice time out you get to eat
whatever you want sit on the bed put her
on the tempur-pedic get her a tub of ice
cream and then give the kid to somebody
who can't have it i always thought that
was the way to do it give her some
pickles you know they get weird cravings
give her pickles a tub of rocky road pop
the baby out and then give it to a
family but why is it so hard to adopt a
kid
i i think everything is about
i hate to say it and i don't want to
sound like a paranoid person but it's
really all about
it's all sex trafficking no it's
it's what it seems it's true it's like
cps the child protective services
is like and i want to have a eliza blue
on the uh human trafficking do you
follow her
i want to know if she knows anything
about the cps because they're they're
they're crazy what they do they just
take kids and then you know they go
you know they nobody knows what happens
to the kids but they they take them out
of these situations that are supposedly
bad and i'm not saying that all of these
situations aren't bad but these kids end
up in foster care and
in the link between that and trafficking
it's crazy but i think we need to make
adoption easier but what i'm saying
about uh this is when you
guilt me and you attack me and say
you don't because you've said multiple
times to me when i had my mansion in
palm springs or my my uh big big uh kind
of like a mini mansion in the valley and
you were like oh you don't need this but
i told you a million [ __ ] times i
wanted to have a christmas party with
logan paul and barry weiss that's the
whole [ __ ] point of having the square
footage is to is to have a party with
everyone and and you do and you demean
i'm just saying i don't want to be
demeaned
tell them about the rental chart so it
says here that uh like if you look at
the chart here 2020 to 2021 it was down
1.4 but then 21 to 2022 up 17.8 percent
united states annual rent growth yeah
more people are going to be renting from
here on out that seems to be the case
yeah it's gonna be you know we shut it
down
uh we destroyed people's ability to earn
a living and earn income we [ __ ] up
people's credit
you know we we we stopped
you know a lot of forward momentum that
people had in their lives keeps folks
you got to keep your hair it's the only
way to really prevent baldness is to
keep the hair that you have on your head
right you don't have to
use wigs or hair regrowth it doesn't
really work i mean keeps is great it
offers a simple affordable and
stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home 24 7 care and
support keeps as a network of expert
medical advisors prescribers and care
specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality several of my
friends are doing this and it's working
for them
keebs has everything your hair needs
delivered straight to your door with
discreet packaging and proven results
remember prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast when it comes
to your hair save more
spend less
okay
keeps there's only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers generic versions of both of
them at a fraction of the cost
if you're ready to take action to
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com tim
dillon to receive your first month of
treatment for free that key
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon to
get your first month free everybody is
trying to find out what you're doing
online the government private
corporations you got to put a stop to it
okay
data has surpassed oil it's the most
valuable commodity people are selling it
trading it mining it all the time stop
them from doing it with expressvpn
turns out that even an incognito mode
your online activity still gets tracked
and data brokers still get to buy and
sell your data one of those data points
is your ip address data harvesters use
your ip to uniquely identify you and
your location but with expressvpn your
connection gets rerouted to an encrypted
server and your ip address is masked
every time you connect to expressvpn you
get a random ip address shared by many
other expressvpn customers that makes it
harder for third parties to identify you
or harvest your data best of all
expressvpn is super easy to use no
matter what device you're on phone
laptop smart tv all you have to do is
tap one button for instant protection
so
if you really want to go on incognito
mode and protect your privacy secure
yourself with the number one rated vpn
visit expressvpn.com
tim dillon and get three
extra months for free that's e x p r e s
s vpn dot com slash tim dillon go to
expressvpn.com
tim dillon to learn more and get three
extra months for free i you know i just
had a friend of mine who a guy grew up
with from high school looks the same in
high school it's kind of crazy
you know he looks
he looks the exact same this guy came
over the house that we had dinner with
he looks the exact same
as he did
20 years ago in high school it's [ __ ]
insane right
i do too probably but it's not good
said more about me then maybe but
he's in canada and we were chatting
briefly about this
you know
trudeau is authorizing banks
you know trudeau son of fidel castro
is that proven not
let's just say it's true
justin trudeau is authorizing banks to
unilaterally freeze accounts of truckers
and people who support the truckers on
the basis of suspicion alone no court
order required with legal immunity so
this is we've seen over the last year
and the last couple of years people get
de-platformed they kick people offline
freeze people's bank accounts the media
doxes people
i've never this is the craziest stuff
that i've seen in my life other than
kidnapping people after 9 11
and uh putting them in boxes underground
and letting bugs crawl on them and
murdering them that was also bad
and no one that's complaining now
was complaining then but i get it people
felt a little vulnerable but that was
also very bad look into that that was
also not great like freezing the bank
accounts is very bad but i mean it's
people like this has never been done i'm
like well not really people just picked
up at airports and then tortured
mercilessly for months and they did
nothing wrong and people didn't really
care about that uh all these people that
are on on and on about this and rightly
so they weren't so much on about that
they didn't really care about that now
they're like well it's but this is crazy
that they're uh doing this and let's
watch this woman i mean
this is insane when people talk about
social credit score and and heading into
this system
and people go no
you're
you're a [ __ ] conspiracy guy not
gonna happen
well it's not gonna happen here
already we're marching towards that very
quickly in
canada it's not is it's like
our northern neighbors
so let's see what's going on here we are
broadening the scope of canada's
anti-money laundering laundering and
terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies that's right
the illegal blockades have highlighted
the fact that crowdfunding platforms
and some of the payment service
providers they use
are not fully captured under the
proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing act
our banks and financial institutions are
already obligated to report i mean it
really is hard
to see
a future for the world
that doesn't involve just ordinary and
now again please i mean
i don't even want to
say this because you know
we're on like one of these things
this is a satirical [ __ ] it's a comedy
show and i'm a satirist right
but that having been said
it is hard to imagine a future and i
don't want this
okay
i don't want this but it's hard to
imagine a future
that doesn't involve regular people
engaging in acts of terrorism against
the government
and i don't want that to happen
but i'm trying to imagine a future
where i don't see like as i go to bed at
night when i'm thinking about what could
happen in the future i'm trying to
imagine a future
where regular people
certain portions of them are not tempted
to take up arms
against it governments if
governments basically go okay peaceful
protests are not allowed
and we can take all of your rights
and we can force your kids to be masked
and we can destroy their quality of life
and we can destroy your quality of life
and we can take all your money and and
and and we're coming out of this in
states
but in canada they're just you know
they're still [ __ ] with them
and the truckers who
have been largely it's been peaceful and
of course the media's you know planted a
few swat stickers and done all you know
i mean
the opposition you know they've done
what they can do to try to frame these
people as racist psychopaths but it
isn't true they just don't want to get a
vaccine
uh that's efficacy has been in
certainly some level of debate
um and they don't believe they don't
want mandates they don't want these
things and and and they're doing
peaceful protests and blockades
and
but again i mean it's not
you know
they're not looting and lighting things
on fire right from what not that i've
seen i've seen they're not engaging in
like
violent they're not ripping people out
of cars
but the government's now going we're
coming and taking all the crypto
and we're taking any funding you're
getting anybody that's supporting you
we're going to take because we don't
agree
now black lives matter they said
millions and millions of unaccounted for
dollars and everybody was supporting
that and a hollywood celebrity and
everybody's going out and going hey this
is great and
and all the money and amazon all these
big companies were like we're supporting
you but this
people are like if you send money to
them we're going to freeze your account
your money laundering
if you're supporting this cause at all
if you're supporting this cause in any
way with money with crypto we're going
to come after you and and
so i'm trying to imagine a future and
i'm hoping i hope that i can do it
but i'm trying to imagine a future where
you don't eventually see if these types
of things continue
people that are truly hopeless and
destitute because now they don't have
any money and they can't get into their
bank account you know i i'm trying to
imagine a future where people don't get
radicalized and
you know start
acting up
but
i don't know i mean
we're in toronto we still have tickets
available march 16th
that that show will be happening we've
been told
we've been told it's gonna happen
that's what i think
i and i i'm i'm
cautiously optimistic about that
let's talk about this uh disney story
because
part of what
i find very interesting all the time is
what disney
does they're a very interesting company
they're incredibly secretive
they don't let anybody in
remember at the end of the florida
project didn't have to shoot that with a
phone because nobody can nobody can film
in disney world there's never been
really a good disney documentary right
right he's never been a dark disney and
you know [ __ ] goes down but you know you
know what i mean i get a bad feeling
from disney world i have some jokes in
my act about it
i don't like it
and it doesn't mean that i don't
recognize its contributions
to the american cultural landscape i
don't really
you know not a ton of them
but
it's it's a disease
kind of it's a sickness
you know
and i don't and i don't know what can be
done about it because people adore it i
even respect
people that love it and people like it
and
it's it's this
eternal
peter pan syndrome
uh that that people have people
people really
enjoy their childhoods
and if if they feel that they've been
slighted in any way during their
childhood or if they've missed anything
they have to continually make up for it
all the time that's why they had these
crazy things like the adult uh summer
camps where people that didn't get a
chance to go to summer camp would then
go as an adult
and instead of going well i'm not going
to get everything out of life you can't
get everything you want you can't have
every experience some people are unable
to admit that they just missed out on so
you can't go back to college at a
certain age it's uh not the experience
you would have had right but disney
world doesn't seem to be like that
people just connect with it at any age
and they just feel and it's it's odd and
whatever and and
and so now these these people who are
again
they're unwell
they're not well people
but something is happening now where
they're
they're be they're they're marketing to
them
and they're they're god help us now
there are disney communities
explain that to people so it's a new
master plan community and they're going
to do it out in uh out in the coachella
valley where walt disney famously lived
out there but this is going to be in
california in california yeah this is
going to be you're a part of disney all
the time so the the water is gonna be
that crystal blue turquoise somehow
constantly uh flowing through the river
here's here's what it says here have you
ever visited a disney theme park resort
with its perfectly manicured and clean
scrubbed grounds by the way that's not
true
a lot in a lot of the cases
but listen listen to even how sick the
article sounds
have you ever visited a disney theme
park resort with its perfectly manicured
and clean scrubbed ground whimsical yet
reassuring architecture why use the word
reassuring
do you see how sick it is do you see how
sick it is
reassuring what it what are you what do
you need to be reassured of
through the architecture
okay
clean scrub grounds whimsical yet
reassuring architecture
chirpy employees and general sense of
cheery optimism and thought
how great would it be
if you could take a permanent residence
there
that's the sort of idea behind the mouse
house's latest venture disney branded
master planned home communities god help
us
today the company announced story living
by disney again the the coupling of
words
story living
fills me with a sense of dread
story living by disney i'm scared about
what the next few lines of this will be
which will be a part of the same
division that oversees its theme parks
disney cruise line
and other experiences the first
community which will be known as cotino
because it's by coachella which is the
fairgrounds out in the desert by palm
springs where all these rich kids go and
dress like uh native americans your
headdresses and demoli and jump around
to 21 pilots
now
by the way
this may be a better use of the desert
than that
let me not judge it's kind of a
throwaway part of the world over there
it's pretty
uh
just a bunch of people so the first
community which would be known as cotino
and include about 1900 housing units
will be in the palm springs city of
rancho mirage california i'm getting
scared now i'm 10 because we're about to
cover something in the hamptons i'm very
very scared about what's happening here
this is not good
palm springs if you've ever been out
there is a [ __ ] cool
community 1950s there's old mid-century
modern homes
old cars
really cool
history there's a lot of [ __ ]
hollywood you know famous old hollywood
sinatra and all this [ __ ]
i'm i'm a little worried now that some
that cotino
is about to open a a community for sick
i'm gonna tell you right now
there is a mobile home park in florida
full of pedophiles
okay
i'm telling you right now
between having to live there or cotino
i'm torn
quote there's incredible demand for all
things disney our fans continue to look
for new ways to engage with us
to keep disney as part of their lives
says josh diamaro chairman of disney
parks experiences and products
at the branded communities he has you
could be part of disney all the time
wouldn't it get
wouldn't it get a little sick
don't you think you'd get sick of it
on day i don't know
maybe maybe would take these [ __ ]
to like month three
you know the end but don't
don't you think
eventually you'd say to yourself oh i've
had enough
as for the story living name this is
truly chilling it's
chilling
i was talking to a guy once i forget but
i think it was on grindr it might have
been on craigslist it was very
it's a long time ago and i said
something to him
and he said a chill ran down my spine
which wasn't good
i don't know what i said but he said it
a chill just ran down my spine but then
he stopped talking to me i think it was
bad
as for the story living name
communities will capitalize on the
company's sense of storytelling and
place making instead of telling mickey
mouse tales however they will focus on
the culture history experience food and
other attributes of the places in which
they will be built
coachella
plans call for a centerpiece lagoon with
a beach that will be accessible to
members of the community's private club
every single element of these
communities will be steeped in a story
the residents he says will be active
participants in the stories
what
i don't even know what that means
what does that even mean i don't know
they have an ad here for it let's watch
this ad we can legally play this because
it's this is sick okay here we go if i'm
telling you right now
if if if you were going
if this excites you in the least
you have very
deep
problems
if there's anything about this if if you
are responding to this in any other way
than what is appropriate which is a
proportional sense of horror and fear
i'm afraid
how many areas will they ruin with this
i'm afraid and by the way
dizzy wait till
marvel
gets involved hey who likes batman
you want to live with spider-man all the
time
and maybe it's dc don't at me i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm saying when disney
starts these fantasy communities for
sick [ __ ] who just want to live in a
[ __ ] uh movie for the rest of their
lives all of these mega
corporations are they're just gonna
build a big nike town and everyone's
gonna be walking around to dump sneakers
i'm telling you it's trouble troubles
are brewing and if you don't see these
trends for what they are if you don't
see these trends
as a massive problem
it is
i can't help you
if you don't think if you think it's a
good idea for disney to build
communities
a corporation like disney world to build
communities that look like movies for
people to pretend to be in a movie all
day
if you think that's a good idea then i
can't help you let's watch the ad
now disney storytelling and world famous
disney service
inspire something new i'll take you
there charming home communities where
the story is all about
you
story living by disney
[Music]
i can't wait till the first guy kills
his wife and they go well this wasn't
part of the story
i'm telling you man it's disturbing
because it's only the beginning right
i mean it's only the beginning what
about buckies they'll have a community
too probably buckies why not
the big what is it a beaver yeah it's a
big beaver yeah the big walmart beaver
that everybody loves bucky's it's a big
walmart type of store with a beaver why
not have a bucky's plan community
bucky's beaver where instead of water in
the fall it's corn
syrup i i'm telling you man
this is the beginning
of
corporations designing communities
um
and by the way blackrock all these guys
they'll all get in bed with this they go
yeah you can rent
you can start you can rent here and then
eventually
some of cotino's neighborhoods will be
designed for residents 55 and older
a market which disney seems especially
interested in
families with young children and people
of all ages will be able to purchase
properties
you think there'll be a hood
you think there'll be a rough area in
disney
like do you think cotino will have a
hood
you think there'll be a rough area in
the disney community i hope so
you think there'll be any area in the
disney community where they'll just
open-air drug markets fentanyl
needles people getting shot
quote baby boomers are moving in
retirement they're going to be moving
into retirement communities that's true
says daryl fairweather chief economist
for seattle-based real estate brokerage
redfin
why not have it be a disney branded
retirement community oh i don't know
daryl [ __ ] common sense
taste decency dignity daryl
if you heard any of those words
have you [ __ ]
ever come in contact with any of those
concepts perhaps google them why not
have it be a disney branded retirement
community i don't know because hopefully
not every elderly person is [ __ ]
insane
disney world should be a four day thing
you put mickey mouse ears on grandma and
grandpa it's hot they take naps you have
a [ __ ] mickey waffle and you get the
[ __ ] out of there you don't live there
for the rest of your life you sick [ __ ]
how much do you want to give to how much
do you want to give this corporation
their movies aren't even that good how
much do you want to give these people
how would you want to get this nazi in
his [ __ ] cartoons
how many pounds of flesh must you
deliver them
proof of vaccination is no longer
required to get into disney park well
that's nice
disney says that amenities will include
live entertainment wellness programming
and seminars
plans call for centerpiece lagoon yeah
we went over that
there will be public components of
cotino as well including a hotel
and entertainment dining and here's what
disturbs you better people are going to
love it oh yeah ah people i mean
are i mean
people are going to love it so much and
this is what scares me
they're going to go [ __ ] palm springs
all that history and [ __ ] it i want to
go to cotino
a community built 15 minutes ago by
corporate psychopaths
and i i
i want to visit cotino cause my cousin
just moved there they're doing they're
story living in cotino what's that well
living's not enough
see that's how they came up with story
living an executive sat in a room and
went living's not enough
people need a story
we got to give them a story
well can't they create their own stories
here we thought they could but
apparently they can't
that's why they keep coming back to our
[ __ ] park
so we've created a story for them we've
built a community where the water is uh
blue it's like gatorade colored
nothing's real
everything's ugly and neon and brightly
colored and everyone's happy in every
moment of the day no matter who's
getting raped
everybody's thrilled no matter how
diseased and drug addicted and no matter
the famine that's going on outside of
these gates they're chirpy and happy
because we think disney should be about
happiness no matter what the hell is
going on we don't care outside of cotino
the world will be going to hell in a
handbasket but we put up those gates and
put a lot of guys with guns outside and
inside it's all mickey waffles and
smiles because it's cotino now if it
works it won't stop with disney it will
expand other
carl's jr will have a community
i'm telling you all of these
corporations they will keep doing this
they will realize that people need their
entire lives to be planned and managed
for them
and and they will try to provide people
some refuge from the horrors of
existence by creating these serene
corporate environments of like-minded
people and you're going to live around
all these people who saw lady in the
[ __ ] and it had such an effect on them
that they never wanted to do anything
else with their life and they're gonna
live in these places and it will never
it's not gonna stop with disney disney
will be the most successful and the
biggest but then other other companies
are going to start to do this as well
all the [ __ ] dc and marvel and all
that comic book [ __ ]
despite bearing its name disney will not
own the communities or be the developer
of record
nor will it be building or selling the
homes it will be partnering with third
parties to handle those functions
because they want to keep their hands
off it for when it gets sticky right
right
however disney's fabled imagineers the
band of creatives who bring the parks
animatronic pirates to life will have a
hand to design and continue and future
community as for the public face of the
communities disney will manage the
marketing and sales efforts and once the
communities are up and running it's
quote cast members disney speak for
employees cast members
cast members
oh is that person being nice to me no
they're it's uh they're an actor it's a
cast
oh i like living is that what it's gonna
be it's gonna be like the beginning of
beauty and beast bonjour bonjour
welcome to starbucks in cotino
would you like a coffee how are you
your daughter's cutting herself she has
issues
but don't worry it's all smiles incotina
it's happy time
we're happy no matter what
turns out that the legendary founder of
the company owned a home and frequented
the coachella valley region in which
cotino will be located
walt disney treated the area like his
creative oasis says michael hundren
executive producer with wolte's
imagineering we love our residents to
treat this as their creative oasis and
explore the next chapter of their lives
quote walt disney loved the coachella
valley because of the weather and famous
lack of jews
odd that they would put that
strange
according to redfin disney will tightly
control the communities that could bring
both pros and cons to homeowners there
would okay ready there wouldn't be a
quote rowdy bar down the street or
obnoxious new music from your neighbor
yeah of course
you're buying in to a complete it's
completely gonna be controlled but it
would come at the cost of your own
personal freedom that wouldn't sit well
with everybody but some disney devotees
who like the company's brand and values
would welcome the careful curation of
the community by the way the personal
freedom giving that'll people will love
that
they don't care
i love when people go yeah it's not
going to be for everybody to complete uh
surrendering in their personal fruit
well by the way over the last two years
it's been for a lot of people
i mean
it's interesting because they're
creating a community it's a corporation
uh with obviously they've created an
entire world of cartoon animals
and cartoons and
famous films and music
and they are saying people let come live
in that world and not the real world
where there might be a rowdy bar or your
neighbor might have music leave that
world come live in our world that's
completely curated and everybody's nice
to you not because you're a good person
or you deserve it it's because they are
cast members in a movie that we are
making which you will be the star of if
you buy our [ __ ] house for however
much it's going to be
well disney had grand ambitions to
develop a working city with residents
what kind of residence walt
which would have showcased the latest
technology because he was a nazi that's
why that's funny so when i say what kind
of residence waltz it's a nazis
he does the project epcot which stood
for experimental prototype community of
tomorrow what did that mean walt
after his death at 66 disney's
successors re-interpreted his vision as
a theme park epcot that exists today
well i mean here's the thing we wish
them all well right i mean
uh this is very disturbing and i'm glad
we got into this because i'm uh uh very
bothered by this but like anything else
i'm not gonna you know what am i gonna
be able to do
we'll probably be there in the catina
steakhouse it won't be bad
i'll be in cuttino like anyone else
eating ice cream
people go hey remember when you i said
shut up
i'm just sitting there eating a big
mickey sunday it's 112 degrees
in cotino maybe i'll live in cotino
who gives a [ __ ] anymore what's the
point
it's the point of anything
if they're all happy maybe it works
who am i to say
come on this [ __ ] show and i yell
about people people just want to be
brainwashed until they [ __ ] go in the
ground
let them
what's the problem
logo live in cotino
ship station if you're running an online
business and who isn't you're going to
need a back office that works for you
and allows you to stay doing what you're
doing whether it's being creative or
growing your business figuring out ways
to market yourself and get out there
it's highly competitive all you need to
worry about and focus on is how to
acquire more business more clients more
customers let ship station handle the
rest okay
they will be your back office they'll
manage every order amazon ebay etsy or
from your own website from anywhere even
your phone no more headaches from
dealing with returns and return tracking
shipstation makes it easy save money
when you compare carrier options and
choose the best shipping solution every
time ship station works with every
carrier so you can always find the best
fit for you your business can access the
same discounted rates usually reserved
for fortune 500 companies okay
save your sanity knowing your orders are
handled and you're getting the best
rates make shipping the easy part of
having an online store you have bigger
ideas to think about no wonder 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business it's that good
use my offer code tim dillon d-i-l-l-o-n
to get a 60-day free trial that's two
months free of no hassle stress free
shipping just go to
shipstation.com s-h-i-p-s-t-a-t-i-o-n
dot-com click on the microphone at the
top of the page type in tim dillon it's
a great way to support our show and get
a great back office that handles all of
your shipping for your online business
shipstation makeship happen
simply safe
i'm telling you right now we have
wireless outdoor cameras it is so good
because basically you want to be as
secure as you can right now and going
forward
simply save us everything you need to
keep your home safe from entry in motion
sensors to indoor and outdoor cameras
simply safe is monitored 24 7 by
professionals ready to dispatch police
firefighters or emts to your home simply
save is less than a dollar a day
and you get to set it up around in
around 30 minutes there are no long-term
contracts or commitments you and your
wife use this and love it we just set it
up at our house it was super easy it's
super easy
and it's because i live in a high-end
luxury building with all kinds of
security indoor and out and multiple
celebrities but you and your wife do not
that's correct
so
you're kind of out there in the streets
not really because we have simply saying
well right
sure
you can
customize the perfect system for your
home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.com
tim dillon go today and claim a free
indoor security camera plus 20
off
with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com
tim dillon that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash tim dillon
i want to complain about this one other
thing before i get out of here because
i'm like alarmed by this and i went to
this restaurant the other day
uh called 75 maine in southampton it's
like a well-known restaurant and
the food was really good they had a
lobster quesadilla that was sick and the
owner took a picture with me or maybe
not the owner the manager i was i was i
was
it was a great experience all in all i
was very happy
and and and and here's the thing man
you're getting a reality show
and i'm like
first of all guys let me let me tell you
right now
the era of reality tv is over
it's like done
you're not even going to get famous
anymore
you're not going to make any money
you're barely going to launch a product
the era of reality tv
is uh done now you are truly scraping
the bottle bottom of the barrel you're
going to make more as a waiter there
than you will
being paid to be on reality tv
now the hamptons are supposed to have a
little class a little dignity it's not
like california where people just speed
around in maseratis
and drive them off canyons
you know what i mean
people in the hamptons new york east
coast old money they're supposed to pull
up and like beat her cars
shittier cars they're not supposed to be
flashing they live in these big estates
behind hedges and gates but they're
supposed to you know relax a little bit
right
it's part of the ethos of
the hamptons it's kind of what's a
little cool about it it's a little more
relaxed
and this idea that they're having a
reality show
it it it it disturbed now i know
everybody wants to be famous and have
opportunities and i'm not trying to take
that away from anyone but i also am
because enough
it's not gonna happen
just make the lobster quesadilla well
it was very good keep making it good
probably had a runaway hit with the
vanderpump rules about the hollywood
restaurant sir
all the restaurants from vanderpump
rules are disgusting
the food's horrible and they're fun
because all the bartenders i guess use
drugs and
i don't know have sex with each other
and then try to kill each other whatever
people like
but
now page six is told that southampton
hotspot 75 main is going to be setting
for a similar show owner whoever
and his sexy staff will be starring on
serving the hamptons which will air on
discovery plus
we're told kendall jenner ivana trump
paris hilton brook shields patriots
owner robert kraft billionaire john
cassapetidis anthony scaramucci and
rapper takashi 6-9 who once left a 2000
tip after ordering thanksgiving takeout
all stopped by the restaurant while
cameras were rolling everyone keeps
calling me the male east coast version i
don't want to rain on anyone's parade
here but what the [ __ ]
i i
mean the whole point of the hamptons is
people that have a lot of money
pretending to not
like care about all this [ __ ]
is the people that they're talking about
kendall jenner ivana trump arizona brook
shields patriots owner robert kraft
these are simple people
they don't want any publicity
they don't want it
when people like kendall jenner
paris hilton they when they leave their
house they're trying to they're trying
to stay low
it's not fair that they're now forced to
participate in this
the cameras will go back to where now
i'm gonna have a problem in here when i
go in here because i like the lobster
case today they're gonna get mad and
they're gonna well you said that we
shouldn't have a reality show why can't
we be fake can't you just do what you do
well how about that you're more famous
than people on tv
75 maine is famous to richfox who gives
a [ __ ]
what these animals think who watch this
[ __ ] from their bathtub while they're
making meth
you got a great ra isn't it enough for
anyone anymore to do the thing you do
well
everybody needs to be a star
everyone needs to be a star
it's sad
the guy who lords over it all and tries
to keep his staffers in check while
handling crisis along with some help
from pr guru tajpiro admits quote
sometimes i want to move to the staff
house it's like the playboy mansion
make
the quesadilla
[Laughter]
the summary includes plot lines like
quote
ethan thompson develops a crush on
brogan but after she puts him in the
friend zone he goes while breaking the
house rules pursuing a different
housemate as well as secretly hooking up
with a local
ketchup
can i have more ketchup please
no matter the house drama the staff must
put their personal issues aside to serve
some of the wealthiest and most demanded
clients
uh i'm gonna move to cotino
do you see this
if they're going to ruin the hamptons
with reality shows
and they're going to go this route i'm
i'm telling you right now we're gonna
have a real problem
because this is not what it's supposed
to be about now i know it's on discovery
plus and no one will watch
it's true
but
if this is the
direction it goes in out there we got a
real problem
it's it's a little disgusting
not everything can be la not everybody
can be just a [ __ ]
with their puss
out can't
can anybody have any dignity
isn't it enough to just make the
the eggs benedict nicely for everyone
i mean
doesn't this bother you it's upsetting
that hamptons is a sacred place it it's
it's a sacred place
it's disgusting the way they're behaving
now it's not right
i can't believe they're allowing this
but i don't know why
and if i have to
wage a war against this to save
the any because these people have had a
lot they've it's not been easy for the
people who live in hamptons
and uh with all of their friends going
you know to jail or
being you know getting in trouble for
the you know the island activity it's
not easy now when you have this going on
it's not right
so it leaves you no choice
but to move to cotino
as much as i insult it
i now i now look at the way the world is
going
why not do a reality show with prince
andrew and the queen mum
how about that is that next
is that on discovery plus with that
sweaty freak
you know andrew i had to donate two
million dollars two million dollars what
did you do with that gal um
i don't tell you
the whole thing's disturbing
you know
i'm i'm bothered i don't want to deny
anyone opportunities i just reality
television is over it's
over where are the people from
vanderpump rules now yes they're
probably better off than they were
before but where are they now
i don't think it's you know
i don't think it's that great
by the way
but i get it they put some money
together i i get it's better than you
know
and this is their chance right because
they're working in hamptons they see all
these celebrities to go i'm gonna be a
celeb because these these these uh
production companies go you're gonna be
a star you're not just gonna be a [ __ ]
on camera
smacking some other [ __ ] because you
had gotten a fight with somebody about
the guy you're [ __ ] you're gonna be a
star
you're gonna have a white wine spritzer
brand
you're going to be a trillionaire
because it worked for one chick you
worked with bethenny frankel on the
housewives of new york who came out with
skinny girl margarita back when you can
still call people skinny and it not be a
hate crime
uh and she made like 20 or 30 mil from
that 20 or 30 sticks
from that but i'll tell you right now
it's not
what it used to be
and i i do think that people have to
kind of realize that
and
understand that
reality shows are not
uh
in the zeitgeist anymore i mean
other than a few of them that have been
around forever and they've kind of been
established but i just don't like
because i went to this place i'd never
really been there i've been there like
once or twice it's a good food it's
actually good
so i i i
you know what i mean
i don't want
the good people
of the hamptons working class
they're working class people
they're simple people
i don't want them to have to deal with
this intrusive
boorish behavior
here
slightly disappointed with that
dates come see me live
if you want to san antonio sunday please
buy tickets there's a few left there's a
lot left
san antonio texas to majestic theater
portland maine you know how i feel
the merrell auditorium
there's already circulating on red it's
like who's this piece of [ __ ] why would
he why would he say he's not funny this
isn't funny about portland it's not
funny i love comedy and he's not
funny
so i get it
i'm like a huge fan of comedy
providence rhode island the veterans
memorial coliseum thursday february 24th
friday february 25th ridgefield
connecticut the ridgefield playoffs
saturday albany new york the egg
sunday february 27th concord new
hampshire capital center for the arts
toronto uh march 16 toronto ontario
meridian hall
baltimore maryland friday march 8th
saturday march 19th philadelphia
thursday at park's casino thursday uh
the 24th of march nashville tennessee at
the ryman special taping uh the 26th at
denver
glasgow scotland march 30th
april 2nd dublin
and then uh we're in london april 4th
6th
so here's the deal folks come we're also
going to try to get to charlotte new
orleans some other places as well in
early march jacksonville
round this tour out finish it tim
dylancomedy.com for tickets uh we will
update you tim j dillon on instagram and
twitter if you want to follow there tim
dylancomedy.com of course
we'll have all of our updates on it and
then uh my special live from cotino
uh
we'll be out where i dress up as the
clock from beauty and the beast and do
my entire stand-up set
and then uh blow my brains out and
splatter blood
all over the 55 and over community
that has uh called cotino
home god help us
god
help us
what they should do what american
truckers should do
is
when cotino is built
they should do what they're doing in
canada right now they should do
blockades so that they can't get food
in and out of cotino
so that the people that have chosen to
live in this fever dream
die out so they can't reproduce
that's the movie
good night